so one doctor is gone and the next one
has come on board the time of the doctor
just happened and
honestly a bit of mixed feelings on this
one the
quick headline is did not like it as
much as day of the doctor which i
thought was
amazing most of why i don't feel that
this was an exceptionally successful
regeneration story
hinges on one thing and i'll get to that
in a minute there are a couple of
smaller things some good some bad
um i wasn't a big fan of the fact that
it made it seem like
bringing gallifrey out of whatever
little pocket universe has been tucked
away into
brings the entire time more with it kind
of like what we dealt with in the end of
time
i'm not really liking that because if
the entire war was locked away
with gallifrey in the pocket universe
then how is that any better than it
being stuck in the time lock
that the doctor supposedly saved
everybody from
maybe i misinterpreted that i mean i
suppose that maybe the real fear was
when the time lords come back
they will restart the time war with the
dogs again but it didn't feel like that
was what they were saying again maybe i
misreading it
some little things that i liked i liked
that we finally got
a resolution on why the tardis blew up
and i'm fine with the fact that it was a
tossed offline i
actually kind of like when there's one
or two little lines that kind of fix a
whole lot of problems i always like that
kind of writing anyways
i like that we kind of got an origin for
the silence as a religion which i wasn't
expecting and that was a nice bonus i
like the fact that the
actual transformation from matt smith to
peter capaldi was
so immediate and so sudden that was a
nice change of pace because
at this point we really think we know
what a regeneration looks like so when
that happened it was
whoa okay all the stuff with the
cyberman head i thought was really
clever it was a little bit like wilson
the volleyball you know from
from the tom hanks movie castaway
however ultimately it it didn't feel
quite right to me and it comes down to
the overall feel of the episode
now generally i avoid comparing russell
t davies to stephen moffat they're
running the show different ways and by
and large i prefer moffitt's approach
but i don't like to just compare and
contrast say he's better or he's better
or whatever
but in this case to really illustrate my
point i kind of need to do that
one of russell t davey's big strengths
was that he was really good at getting
you
wrapped up in the moments as they were
happening
his stories don't quite hold up to
scrutiny the way that moffitts do but at
the moment
oh boy you get really wrapped up in it
and that's really what you
need for a regeneration story the feel
of this story though wasn't that sort of
grab you and oh
take you for a ride story it was a bit
more character study
it was a bit more like vincent and the
doctor or the girl who waited it had
that feel to it now those are both
great episodes but having that feel on a
regeneration episode
you're not getting swept up in the story
of what's actually happening
and then ultimately i was left just sort
of waiting for the regeneration to
happen
now maybe on a revisit i like it a bit
better it does have that sort of almost
fairy tale kind of quality to it that i
like in general but i just think
that feel for an episode was an ill fit
for a regeneration story
so my initial impressions
a little bit up and down of course i'm
gonna miss matt smith he what he has
been my favorite up to this point i've
said that before
i am looking forward to peter capaldi
though and i'm very excited to see him
in the part so
i'm obviously still very hopeful for
what's to come and like i said i'll
probably like this episode better
when i go back and re-watch it but
initial feelings ah
not terrific sorry guys you can't win
them all
so till next time council's adjourned